stay in the car stay in the
car
hi7 hello Hi how are you just so you
know we have body cams recording off the
Str please give your license
registration proof of insurance I have
it on me but I left it at home but I
have I have a license in registration
okay okay what why why don't you have
you don't have what your license no I
changed jackets so I left it in the
other jacket and that's at home yeah and
I just left work in the hatter at the
hatter yeah I'm just bringing her home
okay so you don't have a license on you
no but my I have like my license is
registered I'm sorry my license is
registered your license is registered
yes but I don't have it on me okay do
you have the registration for the
vehicle I just changed it this morning
what does that mean my mom went to the
motor vehicle this morning and changed
over our registration to register this
car in Mighty okay do you have the
registration not yet so you have no
paperwork in the car that says this I
have the old one but it got
re-registered this morning okay you take
it out of the
paper
and your name is Courtney
lki you have the insurance for the
vehicle under my mother's boyfriend
though it's registered to
a yes that's your mom's boyfriend yes no
that's my mom she must have changed it
this morning to the you the insurance
for the
vehicle I have this receipt this must be
from this morning okay that's that's
noted that's not your insurance you have
your insurance for the
vehicle she just redid everything this
morning cuz it was her boyfriend's car
and I had to get it
re-registered yeah cuz it's her
boyfriend's car and he was letting me
borrow it so I had to get it
re-registered into my name okay and you
don't have your license
AR I don't think so I had it in the
other pocket of my jacket but no I don't
okay anything to drink tonight no not no
I was working at the hatter yeah
anything to drink though no no alcoholic
beverages no okay do you understand that
you drove uh down the wrong way on a
oneway street yeah the cop told me that
I could just keep going but I made the
wrong turn I don't live around here so I
get confused with all the one ways so a
cop told you to take take
he told me to he told me to make the
right and go home cuz I explained to him
that I took the wrong way
home okay he just pulled us over and he
told us to just make the right and go
home so somebody told you to make a
right turn there's definitely cameras
there that say it too there was a police
I was going down the wrong way but he
told me to just make the right and go
down that the straight road which was
this road
can you verify that uh another officer
um spoke to these females about going
down the wrong way into wway Street uh
on the first
thing were they in a
car what the other officer were they in
the yes they were in the car okay and
they pulled you over or what did they do
yes they pulled us
over
okay took all your paperwork and
everything too no he didn't take any of
our paperwork he pulled over to the side
of us and told us to just make a right
turn and go down the straight
road to be on Washington yes and then
you pulled us over sir okay I'm just
trying to get home I had a long shift I
understand I'm trying to make sure
you're okay to be driving no I'm okay
sir I swear to God I'm okay okay I'm
just gonna drop her off two miles up the
road and then I'm gonna go
home yeah we just got out of work sir we
got out of work at like um
3:30 okay and then we were CLE and then
we were cleaning up so we could go home
okay and you've had no alcohol tonight
no not a single drop of alcohol while
we're earlier in the night but not since
like 10 p.m. okay so if I have somebody
come to uh fields of variety test on you
you you'll be okay you you'll pass the
test I think so yeah but I don't think I
eat that because I'm okay sir okay any
alcohol for you tonight yeah no
I you have riding
available
[Music]
stay in the you just stay in the I just
want to talk to him really quick oh
him sir you're going to do a DUI on me
you sorry I just got out of work I just
want to go home I understand but I I
want to make sure you're okay to be
driving I'm okay okay listen I had like
one or two drinks okay can I just pull
over the car and Uber home do you
believe you're incapable of driving the
vehicle safely are you going to give me
a
DUI that's not to answer my question do
you believe you're safe I'm fine to
drive but if you want me to pull over
the car and Uber home I will I want you
to be safe you're already driving so so
I'll pull over the car and Uber home I'm
not saying you're intoxicated but I'm
going to have somebody come they're
going to perform test on I don't I don't
want to do all that okay but it's not up
to you it's because I don't want to get
in trouble
then if you don't believe you should be
driving then this was this should have
been rectified before you started
driving you should have called The Uber
before you even got a
car please don't do this to me please if
you believe you're safe to be driving
then you have nothing to worry about I
don't know okay can I just how much have
you had to drink two shots okay at one
time like an hour
ago can I just pull over the car and
Uber home no that right now you're
already driving everything's up body Cam
being
recorded So what's going to happen I'm
going to have somebody that going to
come perform the test on you if you pass
then you get to go if you don't pass
you'll be placed under arrest for DUI
and how long will I be in jail for a
couple hours so somebody can pick you
up please don't do this to me I'll just
park in my if you believe you're safe to
be driving then you have nothing to
worry
about that's it can I just fall home as
soon as somebody comes and performs the
test and you pass then you can go
home please officer like I I work really
hard for every day of my
job1 do you have a photo of your license
by chance yeah I
[Music]
do me
this is my old license this is my um
17-year-old license but that's
me okay
[Music]
okay can you please just let me go I
probably should I can't just let you go
unfortunately you admitted to consuming
alcohol I believe you may be intoxicated
too intoxicated could be driving a
vehicle so I'm going have somebody pull
over and I just you're already driving
we're we're past the point of you
pulling over you should have never
driven to begin with if you don't
believe you're okay to be driving I
thought I was okay okay I only had two
shots then you should have nothing to
worry about can you just please let me
know they're going to have somebody come
they're going to perform a test on you
if you pass then you're good to
go okay all right why I can't but can I
just pull over and go home oh we'll
beyond that point again everything's
recorded on body cam I can't just
say why' you pull me over you went down
the wrong way at a one street yeah but
he told me that I was fine I asked my
police dispatch and nobody confir that
ala did he or did he not say we were
fine
to she's saying it
too there the officer that pulled us
over okay well then they should have P
you over and had a better conversation
with you at he told me just to make the
right and I'm I don't live around here I
live in Wayne so I don't understand all
the streets here you work here so you
should be familiar with four months okay
but I don't understand all the oneway
streets okay so it confuses me so I made
the wrong right turn onto a oneway
street okay what happens yeah it happens
and now I'm now you're so I pulled you
over to make sure you're okay to be
driving
yeah I understand that but I just don't
want to get a
DUI well I don't want you to get a DUI
either but I just want my mom to come
pick me up so I can go home
okay why do we have to do all this right
now I'm I'm telling you that I I'm I'm
pulling the car over and I'm going to
have my mom come pick me up to go home
okay but we're again we're beyond that
right you were already operating the
vehicle you drove 10 blocks
maybe right cuz we first we saw you on
first in Washington that's when we first
saw you we're now on Ninth in Washington
so you drove nine
blocks and it took us nine blocks to
catch up to you I understand I don't
know how fast you were going I can't
really 25 okay I just don't want to get
a GUI like I work really hard for my job
and I I'm I'm like I have no money like
I I I don't know what you want me to do
I want you to not drive while you're
intoxicated I want you to Uber home if
you're intoxicated if you don't believe
you're okay to be driving then I want
you to Uber
home I only had two shs okay so if you
if you believe you're okay to be driving
okay then you have nothing to worry
about okay so this officer here is going
to perform some tests on you he'll ask
you some questions and go through his
thing okay and we go from
there uh so
she came down the one way um First
Street made the right onto Washington
and then Boogie so other time we made a
u-turn and then called up to her this is
where we stopped her um she she called
she took her
license yeah West from
first okay she just admitted to taking
two shots about an hour ago what's her
name hi Cy yes okay do you have any do
glasses or contacts or anything like
that I have glasses but I don't have
them on
me okay just uh walk to the
sidewalk
watch1 are using the last name of the
for this vehicle uh can you check you
know why I'm here
because that P over has leave drank a
little bit tonight so I'm here to
perform some tests on you that's okay
with you okay so you wear no glasses I
do wear glasses oh you want to put them
on now I don't have them you don't have
them no do you normally wear eyelasses
always always yes you have or contacts
but I'm not wearing my contacts tonight
you don't have contact here okay there
not any Pockets right just my lava and
um
it's fine it's just like lava my keys
and everything Mak sure fine no weapons
like that so I know it's cold
out can you see the pen I'm holding yeah
what color is the pen there like a
purplish blue okay so I need you to
follow pen the tip of the tip of this
pen with your eyes and your eyes only
keep your head straight understand it
mhm
okay again just favor keep your head
straight okay follow dep front your eyes
only
[Music]
confir
so I know you told how how many how many
drinks do you have tonight two you have
two drinks anything else I have two
shots that's it two shots and what cost
Amigos how long ago was that at 10: p.m.
cuz it was my work co-worker's last day
of
[Music]
work can you take anything else no
nothing like that no I swear to God
that's it two shots that's it we got two
more quick TS okay any issues with your
legs any pain your legs your ankles your
feet so you should have no problem
walking I should be fine
[Music]
okay okay come down here
man up this way what's I'm sorry what's
your first name
Courtney so see this line yep just come
over here you're going to face this way
uh-huh okay face face the turn around
mhm so see this line down here yeah what
you're going to do is you're going to
place your left foot uhhuh on that line
Y do that now you going take your right
foot and place it in front of your left
foot now say like that don't move just
okay one more time
just okay go back go back to just stand
straight now just pay attention don't
walk I just need you to stand in a
certain way okay so take your left foot
put it on that line take your right foot
and place it in front of your left foot
like I'm doing just like that now do not
do not move don't start walking keep
your hands down at your side okay what
you're going to do is you're going to
take nine steps going forward counting
out loud and keep your hands down like
I'm just watch me one two three all all
the way to nine once you get to nine
you're going to turn
around take another nine steps touching
heel toe and count loud one
two three over way n okay keep your
hands down and count loud good two 3 4 5
6 7 8
9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
okay just you um you want to tie that
Shel for me
please
[Music]
okay man last test are you righty Lefty
I'm righty okay so you're going to pick
you're going to choose one foot uhuh
just watch me don't start yet uhhuh
you're going to raise it about 6 in
above the ground like I'm doing okay
with your toes your toes up okay keep
your hands down you're going to count
out loud 1 100,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 TI
say stop if I was sober or not I
couldn't count to to
1,000 not count to 1,000 I didn't I
didn't graduate high school
okay so again if if you don't want to do
the test you don't have to but can I do
like 10 20 30
no you can't say 1 1,000 2 1,000 3 1000
a lot why is that a lot I don't know
it's a lot of math there's no math
you're counting you're just counting to
10 1 1 don't do
yet so again raise it about six inches
above the ground all right you're going
to keep your hands down all right and
you're going to count out loud don't
start yet you're keep doing it until I
say stop all right go wait no not
yet you have any questions no okay begin
1 1,00 2 1,00 3 1,00 4 keep going 4 1
1,000 5 1,000 6 1,000 7 1,000 8 1,000 9
1,000 10 1,000 11 1,00 12 1,000 13 1,000
14 1,000 15 1,000 16 1,000 17 1,000 18
1,000 18 19 1, 20 1, 21 1, 22 1,00 23
1,00 24 1,00 25 man you can stop
okay
yeah uh so man tonight you place on with
d talk okay I find you little to P is up
when am I going to go home don't pull
away you can answer that question after
can I call my boss y you make phone
calls when we get back to where's my car
going to go it's going to
be let you have somebody that can come
pick it
up the passenger junk I guess
[Music]
to
there that bag on you can I drive home
my mom have to come get me your mom's
going have to come get you I have to
pee hold
on hold on you have a bag on you no
what's this hand my phone and my
lava it's my pocket does this come off
no
this fanny pack doesn't come off oh my
fany pack yeah I thought
you that's just all my money from work
tonight please don't take
it you have anything in your pockets
nope just my phone and my
[Music]
lava
it's all my work
stuff you have no weapons or anything
can I keep my lava in my pocket
no what this PE Mas yeah just in case
someone mugs me in this fucking
pound Uber what you get Uber
Uber
you B yep I'm a bottle
girl you have to can you call my boss
cuz he's freaking out he me please take
out my phone and call my boss please
please please please he called me four
times please no please get back to no no
no no please please please pleas you
called me four times grab the
seat
no she said she didn't have a with she
have yeah
it's one female 105 you have a female
service
headquarter call over or
okay uh take a ride with him up the
headquarters get her in the alest
room uh all way from the
toe we go from that uh I keys on the
Chain the key
chain in the car keys
yeah
yeah can you turn the car off for me
take the keys out can press the break no
just take just turn
it all right up up
yeah yeah no I still need it
yeah
we going up do you have the um the vine
and
yeah what do you need
I'm I'm prescribed it's in my passenger
seat like if I don't have it for the
night I'll I I need it it's in your
passenger seat yeah in my passenger do
you have the prescription for it I don't
have the prescription on me now okay you
need it's in my passenger seat there's
no prescription and we're not going to
man we're not going to bring
you okay what do you need it for any any
anxiety yeah anxiety because I have so
much anxiety because I have a dead
father in a fucked up life so can I
please you
can't
back I at this fuing from a br bitch and
then I get arested hey Mike she's saying
she
has on the other seat I it's in the uh I
don't know if you want bring up if
evidence or not it's up to you it's not
evidence
it's okay what she saying any other any
other pass
SE the passenger SE right don't take
it okay so leave it there okay you
believe
it yeah check
it
she's saying it's for medical purposes
but it's not over
there I got you it's by the
seat it's in there got I I would Bing it
up as evidence no it's not evidence it's
my no no no no
that's
okay well we have no we'll talk to our
our
boss
okay I'm not saying it's illegal but
yeah you
are hear me out go for 10
over call for fireworks in the area of
10 Church
call
103 copy show me a
route transporting one female 1025 DS 74
8834 can you guys like do something
about this
my
minutes I'm
sorry
got
standing by you have off standing by
myself and SP making our way to
course it's legal but we still can
uh so I
have oh who's your boss where do you
work do you smoke at work no Nei do I
exactly okay one3 I'm going 20 do we
have a better description of who's your
boss yeah you saying your boss you you
have to call your boss
back okay who's your
boss well you're going to have to tell
us who to call you want to call somebody
we can't just hand you a phone my mom
okay that's
fine all right but you're not taking
my so my oh okay all
right I don't work m i at what so you
lied you told me you worked at Madhatter
huh which one is
it I don't
know
[Music]
Right congratulations we do
too
just take this in or come back and get
it that's
everything I got
this 16 20 uh 7488
4.2 like no you bring it a I carry it
you going to get her yeah I'll get
her yeah man we'll bring it to the
bathroom stay right
there I'm not going to run well you
ain't going to go far anyway you don't
know how fast I am don't what your hands
my hand I in track I in track in high
school buddy
okay this one yeah I've been do this
before oh yeah huh oh yeah
yeah yeah I got
it wait please don't take that come on
fucked up
Christmas Christmas
ped like two days ago Yeah Christmas P
like two days ago yeah so Christmas GI
are over look at the
wall oh God this way
[Music]
sorry right here
yeah SE
sure can I go to the bathroom
okay I don't have anything on me all
right it's it's just policy can you can
I go to the bathroom yeah we'll bring
you in a minut
like okay
this I didn't know she was in here you
normally put them in here for a 20
minute OB yeah until
okay let's put this
[Music]
by sorry sorry on there
nice the
uh
driver for evidence yeah come on you
you're doing it correctly but don't do
it like that grab it
put put it in there yeah grab the
KE
deal with
yeah this guy was said